vous l'avez acheté un éleveur sérieux le
chien oui c'est un éleveur qui n'était
pas priori avait pas de soucis enfin
vous étiez enseigné sur la race le
comportement du chien etc un petit peu
d'accord vous
pourquoi vous avez décidé d'acheter un
chien voilà la base on avait décidé
d'acheter un champ pour pouvoir se
balader avec lui s'en occuper avoir
voilà un animal avec nous
ça va acheter un staff en fait il avait
pas de permis pour cette race de chien
parce que et vous l'avez pris quand même
c'est c'est comment ça se fait que ça
s'est passé comme ça parce qu'en fait
l'éleveur qui nous l'a vendu bon ce sont
des très bons éleveurs il y a rien à
dire là-dessus mais en fait ils nous ont
expliqué que si on disait que c'était un
staff on pourrait nous retirer la garde
du champ donc en fait ils nous ont
proposé de voir un vétérinaire pour
changer la race et vu que c'était
illégal on n'a pas voulu le faire tout
simplement alors sans se permettre de
risque de trois mois d'emprisonnement
une amende de 3750 euros et le retrait
du chien alors
c'est considéré comme un chien de
catégorie 2 il faut un permis de
détention c'est ça voilà j'ai passé un
permis c'est un examen avec exactement
alors vous dites que vous n'y êtes pour
rien dans cette affaire vous insistez
sur le fait que vous êtes toujours bien
occupé vous êtes toujours bien occupé de
ce chien comment se fait-il pour vous
quel est votre version en effet pourquoi
le chien s'est retrouvé dans cet état
alors nous contestons totalement les
faits et vu que l'affaire est toujours
en cours au niveau judiciaire nous
pouvons pas plus nous exprimer là dessus
mais en tout cas ni moi ni mon conjoint
ça me responsable de ce qui s'est passé
et la seule chose dont nous avons pu
être coupable c'est de ne pas avoir vu
que notre chaîne n'était pas bien en
fait
moi je peux dire que aussi avant
l'arrivée de besca et là il y a plein de
gens qui peuvent le témoigner
il y avait pas il y avait pas autant de
il y avait cette influenceuse qui était
venue nous voir la semaine dernière qui
avait posé l'alerte donc vous dites
qu'avant son arrivée chez vous quoi
il y avait pas enfin moi et des
témoignages qu'on a pu avoir justement
et des vidéos qui ont pu émerger de
notre côté parce que nous en fait toutes
les vidéos qu'on a eu et tout toutes les
preuves qu'on a pu avoir il faut savoir
que nous de notre côté on a eu
interdiction de de notre avocat et de la
justice de tout mettre comme ça sur les
réseaux mais on a beaucoup plus
d'éléments que ce qui a pu aller dans
les médias ou ce que tout le monde a pu
voir ces derniers jours et en fait par
rapport à des éléments que nous on
possède on peut vous dire que ouais
c'est c'est quand même et puis il faut
aussi se rendre compte que
je voulais sauveuses là je parle de
cette focuses mais techniquement quand
tu fais 250 Tik Tok tous les jours que
tu invites les gens à créer des groupes
pour des viols pour des agressions que
tu mets des noms de personnes qui n'ont
rien à voir dedans et que tu incite
comme ça à la haine c'est pas très
c'est pas très sachant que sachant
qu'elle n'est pas venue à la
confrontation
alors simplement sur votre version le
vétérinaire lui qui a examiné le chien
raconte qu'il a déterminé qu'il y avait
des fractures antérieures que tous les
toutes les souffrances du chien ne
dataient pas de cette journée mais qui
avait eu des actions violentes contre le
chien avant comment vous les expliquez
nous ce qu'on peut simplement dire sans
rentrer dans les détails c'est que il y
a une personne tierce qui s'occupait de
l'animal et nous on sait pas du tout
rendu compte que le chien était fracturé
ou quoi c'est à dire c'est pour parler
et pour parler du vétérinaire ça aussi
moi je peux le dire parce que du coup
moi je suis déjà passé du coup devant
juge et ayant vu la semaine dernière
l'émission que vous aviez faites
ce qui m'a surpris c'est que entre ce
que vous vous aviez sur le plateau ce
qui était dit sur les réseaux et ce que
il y a eu devant le juge c'est pas du
tout la même expérience de vétérinaire
ça veut dire l'expertise que vous avez
eu c'était juste du copier-coller de ce
que la tiktokeuse avait mis sur les
réseaux mais l'expertise que nous on a
eu avec notre avocat et que la justice
et que la justice a en sa possession
c'est pour les photos quand même
c'est quoi l'expertise
qu'on avait il y avait pas de traces
d'acide ni de cigarettes
après il y avait des fractures
effectivement et après je sais plus
exactement ce qu'il y avait mais c'était
deux alors
il faut rappeler que monsieur est passé
effectivement c'était jeudi on parution
immédiate devant le juge à Pontoise il a
demandé un renvoi du procès et que vous
avez été vous devez habiter chez votre
maman à Bourges chez ça vous êtes il y a
vous devez pointer au commissariat
chaque semaine et vous vous êtes accusés
notamment de privation de soins sur le
chien on est bien d'accord vous serez
jugé plus tard mais vous serez jugé
monsieur justement le report justement
pour revenir à cette histoire c'est
justement on a réussi à prouver que elle
n'était pas dans un état
tu méfier justement avant ce matin c'est
à dire en fait
je veux dire un peu tu méfier non en
fait elle avait sa bosse à la joue du
c'est quoi cette
accident qu'on a pu prouver justement
mais elle avait pas c'est quand elle est
tombée des escaliers ce que vous avez
dit ça a été mal interprété mais en fait
un handicap donc il a du mal à marcher
et souvent ça lui arrive de tomber et en
fait plusieurs fois bah en la promenant
elle elle l'a tiré et ce qui a fait
qu'elle est tombée enfin
non la chaîne enfin Texas
et berlué quoi parce que quand on voit
dans les dans l'état dans lequel se
trouve la chienne et que pour vous il ne
s'est rien passé de votre part et ben on
se dit alors comment comment les matomes
comment la fracture du crâne comment la
malnutrition et comment les cassures qui
ont plusieurs mois qui sont donc
antérieures à tout ce qui vous innocente
soi-disant et justement c'est là où
comme j'ai dit l'expertise de ce fameux
vétérinaire ben elle va elle rentre en
compte elle rentre en contradiction
comme j'ai dit avec celle de celle que
nous on a eu la vraie parce que quand
par exemple nous on a entendu oui ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'il y a des
fractures etc bah nous on était choqué
vu que déjà ça faisait pas plusieurs
mois qu'on l'avait ça veut dire même on
est en mode mais c'est n'importe quoi
parce qu'on a des vidéos justement on a
pu apporter des éléments comme j'ai dit
qu'on peut pas apporter là pour
l'instant parce que l'enquête est encore
en cours on a pu apporter des éléments
où tu on voit très bien que jouer
qu'elle était nourrie qu'elle était et
c'est pour ça que à un moment on s'est
dit bah on voulait parler on voulait
prendre la parole on devait déjà venir
la semaine dernière mais on n'a pas pu
parce que comme on vous a dit c'était
impossible
en fait nous les preuves qu'on voulait
apporter à ce moment-là Cyril on avait
déjà été déjà en contact ça bah ça
prouvé justement certains de nous dire
sauf que si on aurait fait ça c'était
rentré totalement en en travaillant avec
la justice et là on allait devant
d'autres problèmes en fait mais on voit
quand même avec des petites chienne
normale qui n'est pas cabossé on la voit
vous la tenez dans vos bras entre ce
moment-là et maintenant elle a été
régulièrement tabassée on va savoir si
c'est tout le temps le voisin ou
quelqu'un d'autre ou si vous vous y êtes
pour quelque chose c'est ça que je veux
savoir nous après on comprend la colère
enfin la vôtre celle des téléspectateurs
nous-mêmes on est en colère parce qu'on
non seulement on nous a retiré notre
animal et en plus on les met beaucoup et
on a été surpris de plusieurs
accusations comme quoi elle était mal
nutri etc parce qu'on a toujours fait le
maximum pour la sortie pour la nourrir
etc on est responsable pourquoi n'avoir
rien dit pourquoi n'avoir rien fait
parce que quand on fait rien quand on
dit rien on est complice déjà au moins
non ça aussi justement ça c'est une fois
de plus la super sauveuse qui disait
n'importe quoi on a fait justement en
avait rendez-vous avec le vétérinaire ça
aussi pareil personne n'est au courant
mais on avait rendez-vous justement avec
le vétérinaire et en fait ce que moi je
peux dire c'est que certaines choses
peut dire qu'il y a énormément de
blessures qui datent pas de des mois
mais de moins de 48 heures et c'est là
où j'ai j'ai justement ça qui a permis à
la juste de se dire que il y a quand
même en gui sauvage dans cette histoire
et des fractures on a entendu beaucoup
de fois dire que il y avait des
anciennes et des nouvelles et même des
anciennes qui dataient il y a la Chine
avait 4 mois qui datait il y a trois
mois par exemple comment on explique les
anciennes fractures
il y a trois mois c'est impossible ça
voudrait dire que les personnes qui nous
l'ont vendu l'aurait taper parce que
nous on l'a eu après vous l'avez
réceptionné en fait on a une fracture
pourquoi il y en aurait et est-ce que
c'est vrai est-ce que c'est établi euh
non déjà je pense pas et enfin les
fractures ce qui nous ont expliqué
datées de plusieurs semaines donc à
partir du moment où la personne tierce
dont on peut pas citer le nom on s'en
est occuper alors parce que votre
version pour les téléspectateurs il est
20h39 sont directs juste pour vous il y
a une tierce personne qui maltraitait le
chien c'est ça non ça on peut pas on
peut pas
se prononcer ah il reste plus que vous
après par contre c'est ça qui emmerdant
oui mais après il y a après il y a une
enquête c'est ça qui emmerde
surtout pour vous hein
c'est quoi l'histoire parce que on
aimerait leur version sexy il y a une
tierce personne
quand bien même il aurait été massacré
comme ça comment le voilà en 48 heures
si c'est votre chien comme vous vous
êtes rendu compte c'est 48 heures
pourquoi c'est visiblement quelqu'un
d'autre qui a appelé la production des
animaux vous avez un chien qui est en 48
heures devient massacré vous faites rien
vous le voyez pas si c'est que la
personne est venue chez nous et en fait
le matin quand on s'est réveillé la
police a fait une perquisition ça veut
dire qu'on a eu le temps de se rendre
compte de rien en 48 heures vous avez
pas vu le chien était comme ça
bien pris le point parce que ce qui
s'est passé c'est déjà il faut juste
aller sur le Tik Tok de cette jeune
fille vous verrez tout ce qu'elle a fait
ça dure en fait nous on se réveille ça
dure il est 10h du matin on voit la
porte qui littéralement explosé on
comprend pas ce qui se passe on descend
on ouvre la porte déjà la police qui a
nos clés déjà on comprend pas pourquoi
la police les clés de chez nous et sont
dans la résidence avec les clés chez
nous il rentre il nous explique oui vous
tabassez des gens vous droguez des gens
vous séquestrez des gens vous avez tué
des animaux c'est-à-dire nous on serait
on sort du lion on est devant 10
policiers on comprend pas ce qui se
passe ils sont armés et en fait tout
s'enchaînent très vite ça veut dire
on a vu les photos avec vous et
justement ce qui est dommage et bon pour
nous c'est qu'il y a des caméras dans la
résidence il y a des caméras dans ça
veut dire en fait c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit vous n'avez jamais vu votre chien
dans cet état alors c'est en 24 heures
alors c'est pas possible
est-ce qu'il y a un état physique ou
psychique qui aurait pu altérer votre
conscience et de voir que votre animal
était en souffrance voilà on va être
clair euh si ça s'est passé en une nuit
et que vous avez remarqué c'est que vous
étiez à l'ouest et n'hésitez pas en
possession tous vos moyens en gros ça
dure la aucun de vous sur le plateau à
regarder les Tik Tok de cette fameuse
cycloqueuse mais vous verrez que en fait
nous on est parti se coucher vers 21h et
de 21h
et de 21h à 11h du matin c'était une
télé-réalité chez nous ça dure on a
découvert que c'est levé elle était
devant nous avec un couteau ça aussi
personne ne doit dessus mais il s'est
passé tellement de choses que nous-même
au moment où vous parle on était en état
on va voir les Tik Tok de cette jeune
fille regardez
votre French McQueen Roca maltraite son
chien son chiot et c'est son mec et elle
elle fait rien il le frappait
à la ceinture lui mettez des coups de
béquilles
un chiot un bébé ouais il le sortait
jamais [ __ ] il faisait bonne figure
câlin tout ça mais [ __ ] c'est du faux
comment tu peux créer un Instagram à ton
chien alors que tu le maltraites et le
mettre dans des clips alors que dans la
vie de tous les jours le chien il va
mourir c'est je serai pas intervenu il
serait mort il serait mort
vous vous couchez le chien va bien cette
tic-tocqueuse massacre le chien dans la
nuit pour le lendemain vous faire
accuser parce qu'elle vous déteste c'est
même pire que ça c'est 7 que ça fait
trois ans que tous les ans elle trouve
un nouveau truc un nouveau groupe et
qu'elle essaie de faire des attaques
personnelles ou visées pour l'invitez
quand même dans cette soirée
que ça faisait un an qu'on était plus en
contact et en fait si vous voulez être
dans une précédente à faire où on a été
accusé qui a été sans suite au final
vous êtes quoi on a été accusé de viol
et tuer des gens et vraiment classé sans
suite
donc cette personne était dans la ferme
moi ça faisait un an que je l'avais pas
vu elle s'est excusée auprès de moi en
disant qu'elle avait été manipulée par
les autres filles du groupe pour
m'attaquer et
je l'ai revu
admettons vous êtes victime d'un complot
vraiment sauvé le chien nous on est
d'accord dans ce cas là le lendemain
qu'elle est venue sur votre plateau il y
avait une confrontation confrontation
nous on a apporté nos éléments justement
les fameuses vidéos qu'on peut pas
encore montrer à qui que ce soit mais
bizarrement elle est pas venue
l'enquêteur qui est tout fier en disant
oui vous allez aller en prison elle va
venir elle va tout dire on attend
personne se présente on monte nos
preuves à même l'enquêteur et ton
contenu en mode
on apprend par l'enquêteur que le
lendemain elle est jugée parce que elle
maltraite son enfant ça veut dire
nous-même on se dit ah oui mais en fait
dans voilà dans quel film on est en fait
elle nous elle nous juge elle dit qu'on
maltrait des animaux mais on apprend
qu'elle a défoncé le crâne de son enfant
avec une boîte de lait et pourquoi elle
est c'est grave quand même ça c'est quoi
le bosse absolument pas vous faire
tomber mais je pense que vous allez
porter plainte contre elle du coup bien
sûr
c'est victime vous êtes victime elle
visiblement c'est votre c'est votre
bureau mais on nous a parlé donc est-ce
qu'on colporte d'autres fake news d'un
autre chien que vous auriez eu avant
Texas quiz parce qu'il serait mort alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
chien qu'est-ce qu'il est devenu
absolument en fait on a acheté un chien
qui en fait était assez jeune enfin nous
on pensait qu'il avait deux mois et en
fait c'était une petite chaîne qu'on a
appelé Quinny et qui malheureusement
avait des vers depuis le vétérinaire
dans ce cas-là
parce qu'en fait le vétérinaire quand il
a vu tout ce qui s'est passé l'unité de
lui-même nous a appelé et nous a dit
c'est n'importe quoi ce qui vous arrive
il dit à moi s'il y a un problème ou
quoi que ce soit je peux vous envoyer
les documents on lui a dit oui
aux équipes on lui a dit oui s'il vous
plaît envoyez-nous les documents parce
que là on a vraiment besoin du coup
j'avais dormi le chien et il meurt quoi
c'est ça qui est chiant
je viendrai pas dormir chez vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
votre version c'est très structuré vos
témoignages vous dites vous avez des
éléments voyez aux équipes d'accord mais
ça nous paraît surréaliste que vous ayez
laissé quelqu'un une tiktokeuse qui fait
partie de votre sphère dirons-nous
d'abord vous accusez un justement de
viol puis ensuite tapez votre chien vous
criez au complot franchement pourquoi
vous n'avez pas agi avant est-ce que là
vous entre guillemets je me fais
l'avocat du diable est-ce que vous
n'inventez pas tout ça pour tenter que
vous sortir d'un très mauvais pas parce
qu'il faut rappeler quand même que vous
risquez plusieurs années de prison
il y a une vidéo sur Youtube qui dure
deux heures justement parce que on va
nous même on l'a découvert après tout ça
c'est des abonnés qui nous ont dit mais
un mec a fait une vidéo sur vous et en
fait on a découvert qu'un mec avait fait
une vidéo justement de deux heures où il
reprenait tout le pourquoi du comment
pour que me dites-vous nous-même on a
compris pourquoi ils nous en voulait
voir la vidéo de youtubeur c'est à dire
dis-toi que nous l'année dernière qu'on
nous a convocuse moi d'avoir tué 11
personnes parce que ce que là personne
n'est au courant c'est quand même on a
pris 96 heures de garde à vue
c'était des meurtres ça veut dire on a
nos empreintes on était recherchés on
comprenait pas c'est à dire les
policiers nous arrêtent ils disent ouais
vous êtes des meurtriers et cetera
c'est-à-dire ça fait deux trois ans que
à chaque fois ces histoires reviennent
c'est les mêmes personnes on nous de
notre côté on peut rien faire à part se
défendre parce que bah malheureusement
la loi permet pas d'attaquer mais au
bout d'un moment ouais on commence à en
avoir vraiment marre c'est pour ça qu'on
s'isole en tout cas soit la nature que
je mange soit vous mentez mais au final
il y a un chien qui est massacré au
mieux c'est ça ça c'est sûr ça a pas
l'air de vous émouvoir plus que ça quand
même malgré tout
on est tous d'avoir perdu notre chien on
est triste d'être insulté menacée que ça
soit des personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux ou même des animateurs qui nous
condamnent alors que la justice
elle-même n'a pas rendu son verdict donc
bien sûr qu'on est attristé de de tout
ça et enfin voilà en fait
aussi parce que là vous me voyez deux
semaines après donc on a eu le temps de
descendre et en fait là c'est pourquoi
on paraît plus en colère parce que c'est
plus les dommages collatéraux c'est à
dire les parents qui peuvent plus sortir
les frères et soeurs qui sont obligés de
changer d'école
Roca qui se fait menacer de se faire
brûler devant un restaurant avec sa mère
je veux dire des gens qui veulent faire
justice pour des raisons qui pour une
affaire qui sont même pas au courant en
fait des tenants et des aboutissants ça
veut dire oui et pourquoi vous êtes pas
venu avant du coup ça fait deux semaines
on a écouté
parce qu'ils ont pas voulu les avocats
n'ont pas oublié c'est que quand on vous
écoute on a l'impression que vous êtes
les maîtres parfaits en fait vous avez
rien à vous reprocher il y a quand même
des accusations de maltraitance sur un
autre chien vous avez aussi mis en scène
et ça pour le coup il y a des images un
chien a priori sans trop respecter
l'animal on a l'impression que vous avez
rien à vous reprocher effectivement que
vous en foutez complètement est-ce que
vous avez conscience que c'est grave et
que les personnes qui ont fait ça
effectivement méritent d'aller en prison
ce qu'on a l'impression que vous en
foutez non on s'en fout pas du tout
c'est juste que apprécié un peu de se
détacher tout ça pour triste mais vous
avez été un peu détaché vous iriez
risquez de vous retrouver plus attachés
maintenant c'est sûr
que quand tu
te fais agresser pour sa part que une
arrestation plus que musclé et que après
tu as juste un désolé on savait pas bah
ouais ça donne des raisons d'être en
colère quand même mais vous avez utilisé
j'emploie le mot à dessin le chien dans
un clip musical qui a été considéré par
certaines associations comme de la
maltraitance on voit sur le clip que le
chien il a l'air contraint et forcé
est-ce que vous regrettez ça et qu'il a
déjà un œil
il a déjà un oeil ça c'est votre chien
ça c'est avant que les filles
interviennent
[Musique]
pour moi c'était pas de la maltraitance
enfin je pense que je connaissais ma
chaîne mieux que vous ici et les
spectateurs et je pense qu'elle aurait
aboyé elle aurait fait un signe comme
quoi elle était pas contente et enfin
moi je la portais souvent et il y avait
aucun souci là-dessus donc
tu méfier
justement on a dit tout à l'heure
qu'elle avait déjà sa petite bosse mais
comme vous pouvez voir justement elle
était pas
dommage qu'on a vu il y a quand même un
fossé enfin je veux dire elle marchait
très bien il y a toutes les personnes
qui étaient sur le clip enfin je l'ai
pas porté pendant quatre heures les
scènes elles ont duré 10 minutes elle
était par terre elle pouvait se déplacer
enfin je veux dire elle marchait très
bien